hello and welcome to something a little
bit different how the hell are you if
you're an OG Grenadier on these parts
you know that I agreed to make merch
once we reached 850 thousand subscribers
and guess what we actually got there so
first things first thank you so much for
getting me to that milestone 850,000
anyways as promised we now have grenade
merch and I've decided to name the star
grenade gear or GG for shorts
GG's it's only early days so the designs
are a little minimal at the moment so
please shout out what you want in the
comments below and if you see a
character in a thumbnail that you'd like
a t-shirt off just let me know I'll work
with that designer and we'll bring you
whatever you want
I know a lot of people want a hot watch
t-shirt I'm working on it
give me a little more time please there
is one item which I feel is important to
go through right now it's the og the
original grenade tee which is going to
be discontinued when we reach 1 million
subscribers I wanted to have something
like a collector's item for those people
who've been with me from the start and
also if you do buy anything please send
me a photo
oh that sounds weird doesn't it or a
column saying is that I'd like to
include pictures of you guys repping
grenade gear in videos so hit me up on
Twitter if you do buy anything
I'm Adam grenade and my DMS are always
open the hot watch t-shirt is coming
soon so stay tuned but I'm looking for
designs and ideas so please use the
comments below to say what you want I'll
hire some talented designers and we'll
bring your ideas to life thanks for you
time peeps I really appreciate it and
thank you so much for 850,000
subscribers
my mind is blown I'm Adam grenade this
is grenade gear thank you very much for
your time much love I'll see you soon
[Music]